first on CBS this morning new TSA data
shows a record number of firearms were
discovered at airport checkpoints last
year more than 4,200 guns were found at
249 airports nationwide and more than
86% of them were loaded in December a
months-long CBS News investigation
obtained security camera and police body
camera video of firearms discoveries at
dallas-fort Worth International Airport
Kris Van Cleave is at the security
checkpoint at Reagan National Airport
where 16 guns were confiscated last year
Chris good morning good morning at the
airports that found the most guns they
were in the Sun Belt stretching from
Atlanta to Arizona states that typically
have looser gun laws we dug through
thousands of pages of police documents
trying to understand why the numbers
keep growing and we found that while
thousands of guns are spotted by TSA
screeners some appear to be getting
through a gun inside a carry-on at
dallas-fort worth a scene that played
out 219 times last year at that Airport
alone
nationally it happened nearly 12 times a
day passengers almost always say it was
a mistake as this man did in 2017 the
more than 4,200 guns stopped at TSA
checkpoints last year was a 7 percent
increase over 2017 just 10 airports
accounted for nearly 1/3 of all cases
Atlanta had the most with 298 found in
carry-on bags why do you think that
number is growing every year I'm just
gonna make a guess here I think more
people are just simply carrying weapons
in the country and we reflect what we're
seeing around the country how you doing
TSA administrator David pukowski when
you go into a TSA screening checkpoint
you know you're there I mean it's it you
just don't happen upon that before you
hit that first person in line
just take a quick look through your bag
TSA is working with airports to improve
signage reminding people guns cannot be
in a carry-on the agency also
demonstrates properly packing an
unloaded firearm in a locked case in a
passenger's checked luggage all we ask
is that you do
Paquette properly to ensure its safety
the safety of everybody else otherwise
you could risk arrest like here in
Dallas
the TSA can also seek fines up to 13
grand but not all guns are found last
month screeners in Atlanta missed one in
a man's carry-on and our review of 2017
police records from seven airports found
at least three cases where it appeared
guns got through the checkpoint I'm a
little troubled by the fact that the gun
went through the x-ray machine and was
missed
oh I'm troubled by that too I think
everybody in TSA is troubled by it we do
everything we can to figure out why it
happened our investigation found in 2017
the vast majority of the people who
brought the gun to the checkpoint were
men sixty-three percent were white
typically between their 30s and 50s but
guns were found in the carry ons of an
84 year old woman a ten year old boy an
airport worker and a pastor Norah what a
story Chris thank you I mean I always
get dinged for a bottle of water yeah
they confiscated my contact lens
solution last week because I the bigger
ball that's it but it hasn't been open
yet it doesn't matter I'm surprised
though it how many people can carry a
gun and forget they have it do you are
you guys surprised by that I guess what
these concealed weapons laws to you just
keep it in a purse you just don't think
about this is a nice saying this
off-camera I mean this is really an
American story right any much any
Western countries having this issue with
more than 200 million guns of America
alright Chris thanks again